but in big football news did you hear
the rumors that tom brady's may be
retiring yeah i'm not sure it's true i
think it's probably just speculation but
if it were me i probably would retire
too if it gave me more time to watch
emily in paris
peyton manning stopped by saturday night
live and he gave a surprising reaction
to tom brady's headlines you know i kind
of feel like a fan doing this show no
need to show off your fan credentials
following your snl appearance peyton
hello
bonjour the nfl star joined weekend
update to share his love for the hit
netflix series so just for fun i put on
the first episode of emily in paris
season two
and i watched the entire season straight
through oh my god colin this show has
everything peyton said he learned an
important lesson from lily collins
character the french have a saying
parlez-vous francais which means you do
you girl
i i'm pretty sure that means do you
speak french i don't speak french colin
but thanks to emily i speak love
and with rumors swirling around tom
brady's potential retirement colin jost
did his best to get payton's
professional opinion but in big football
news did you hear the rumors that tom
brady's may be retiring yeah i'm not
sure it's true i think it's probably
just speculation but if it were me i
probably would retire too if it gave me
more time to watch emily in paris
i really think for tom right now it's
just a tough decision between balancing
his career and relationships sort of
like emily the football news also made
it into the monologue
we're even getting some reports that
russia has already invaded but those are
from the same people who said tom brady
retired so take it with a grain of salt
the grain of salt approach might be best
moving forward i think it's harder to
actually you know be able to take time
and focus on the things that you really
want to do despite initial reports that
tom will soon announce his retirement
new details indicate the five-time super
bowl mvp has yet to make up his mind
tom's agent don yee released this
statement to espn's adam schefter quote
i understand the advanced speculation
about tom's future without getting into
accuracy or inaccuracy of what's being
reported tom will be the only person to
express his plans with complete accuracy
he knows the realities of the football
business and planning calendar as well
as anybody so that should be soon
that's you know up in the air for real
in a recent chat for groupon's party
like a player sweepstakes rob gronkowski
gave e.t his reaction to tom's potential
future with the nfl grunk right off the
bat you teased that you may be back for
another season
will you come back and it's time coming
back with you
oh man well first off you know
you know i can't speak for tom he's got
to make his own decision you know what's
best for him and his family um
you know um
and then personally for myself
i got to take some down time right now
man that season was oh let me tell you